- Where can I find a crib?
Crib, crib, crib, crib.
Crib, crib, crib.
- [Man] Do you just wanna explain
what's happening right now?
(suspenseful music)
- I'm trying to think of
what object I want to use
as the experiment to see if
my phone is listening to me.
I put my phone outside of the room.
The object has to be so
specific, but so unrelated to me
that there is no possibly way
that this ad would be
suggested to me aside
from my phone listening
to me and giving me an ad.
I can not type it on my
phone, can't search for it.
I sound like such a psycho.
Kid-related stuff, like a crib.
- Oh.
- I'm never buying anything
for a kid.
I haven't been looking and
I don't plan on looking
for something like that.
- That's a really good idea.
I like that a lot.
- Is it crib?
- [Man] I think it's crib.
All right.
So because this is science
and we wanna make this
a fair experiment, I'm
going to set some parameters
for myself about how this is conducted.
For the next week, every day I'm going
to say the crib 50 times.
I think that's gonna be
a fair assessment to see
if my phone is listening to me.
Crib, crib, crib.
Does anyone where I can buy a baby's crib?
Taking a walk, gonna go
meet my wife for lunch,
and I figured I'd squeeze
a couple cribs in.
Crib, crib, crib, crib, crib.
Just eating some pizza, crib, crib.
Where do you think I'd buy a crib?
I keep getting excited
because this will be so crazy
if I'm on my phone one day
and I see an ad for a crib.
I wonder if my phone's listening to me.
Does anyone where I can get a crib?
I'm gonna be honest,
it feels a little weird
to sit in my apartment
just saying the word crib
over and over again.
I hope my neighbors aren't listening.
I'm about to go to sleep,
but I thought I should get some cribs in.
Crib, crib, crib, can you hear me, iPhone?
It's day two, just left the gym.
It's a disgusting
morning here in New York.
Perfect time to squeeze in some cribs.
Can anyone hear me?
I'd like to buy a baby's crib.
Of all the words I could've picked
to be saying over and over
again, crib is a weird one.
Crib, crib, crib, crib.
Chelsea, do you know where I'd
be able to buy a baby's crib?
- What are you gonna use that crib for?
- How do you pronounce it?
Crib?
- Crib.
- Crib, okay.
Crib, crib.
Baby's crib, crib for a baby.
Crib.
Grinding at the gym, crib, crib, crib.
I don't know, I'm losing
faith in this experiment.
I think I'm actually getting scared
that I'm gonna be on Facebook
or Instagram or Twitter
and there is gonna be a crib advertisement
and I'm just gonna miss it completely.
And then it's all gonna be for nothing.
I don't know guys.
I've just been cribbing
away all day every day.
I've been really trying to pay attention
to the ads that are on my social media
and so far I've only seen
Dick's Sporting Goods,
there was a movie advertisement,
Glade the air freshener,
a grocery delivery
service, and Volkswagon.
None of which are crib based.
Not even remotely baby oriented.
My ability to say crib
into my phone 50 times
while it's not going
anything is dwindling.
None the less, I really wanna see this out
through the end of the
week because science.
Crib, crib, crib, crib,
crib, crib, crib, crib.
It's the end of the week.
It's the last day of the experiment.
I'm starting to think this was
a gigantic waste of my time.
I haven't seen anything on
any social media platform
that is a suggested ad for cribs.
I thought somebody was listening to me.
If you're still listening to me,
you're making me look like an idiot.
Crib, crib, crib, crib. (laughs)
They're not listening to me.
You have no idea how badly
I wanted to make this work
just by typing a little
crib into my phone.
Just to see if something would happen,
but this is an experiment
and I wouldn't do that to you guys.
Okay, so it's day whatever,
I don't know what day it is
in this experiment,
but I've had a thought.
Whoever listening to me
in my phone is dead set
on making me look like an absolute moron.
So I think I'm gonna
try some other tactics
to get crib as a suggested
ad in my social media.
Some of a bitch, it's my phone now.
Someone texted me crib.
Word must've gotten out about
this experiment I'm doing.
So I don't know, maybe this'll help.
All right, here's the deal.
Maybe my phone is listening
to me, maybe it isn't.
I don't know.
I haven't seen any evidence of it.
So I put a little search into Google Maps.
Not looking for a crib,
but for a Babies R Us.
They've got cribs.
So I don't know if my phone
gonna track me to this store
and then suggest something for me,
but I've got some shopping to do.
Little did I know, I'm on the wrong floor.
I've gotta go to level
three for the cribs.
Something weird is going on.
I get up here.
Half the room is empty.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
So I just left Babies R Us
and I'm not sure whether I should laugh
or chuckle or freak out.
There was not a single
crib in the entire place.
Literally everything but cribs.
I know my phone is listening to me.
Guy, you gotta believe me.
My phone is listening to me,
crib, crib, crib, crib, crib.
I've actually thought about
why it's not coming up
on my phone and I don't think
I've been saying crib loud enough.
Crib, crib, crib!
Get me a god damn crib.
(sighs) Fuck.
Do you think I'm proud of
the way I've been acting?
I shouldn't be, it's embarrassing.
Now the time has come
to do the unthinkable.
So now it's your move, iPhone.
Listen up everybody, this is
the last day of the experiment.
I can't do this anymore.
If I get to the office and
there's not a suggested ad
for cribs in my social media, we're done.
We're done.
That's it, guys.
It's the end of well over two
weeks of just rambling crib
into my phone.
Went through my suggested ads again.
It's Coca-Cola, it's
Ziploc, Dannon Yogurt.
I really thought this was going to work.
I wanted it to work.
The more I think about
it though in reality,
it's probably a good
thing this didn't work.
So in general, does it mean your phone is
or isn't listening to you?
I still don't know.
That's not for me to say.
In terms of cribs, no it
is not listening to me.